this is
the ramsay show you can be intentional
about your character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's
the ramsey show where debt is dumb cash
is king and the paid off home mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host anthony o'neil
ramsey personality number one
best-selling author of the book
debt-free degree is my co-host today
open phones as we talk about your life
and your money the phone number is
triple eight
eight two five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five
two five so anthony you have spoken now
all over america many many times and
certainly on this show many times
about this idea of how to pay for
college
paying cash for college is college
still a good idea all of these kinds of
things
because of this ridiculous epic student
loan
debacle that our idiot congress
continues to fund
with your money and my money and it's an
obvious failure
it's an obvious blight on the american
people and yet they continue to do this
to the american people
uh and yet walk around talk about
forgiving loans but keep making them
right right so uh something's wrong with
that but you know this idea of paying
for kids college
it's something that families that are
building wealth
always want to look at yeah yeah and
here's here's the reason why dave is
because
it's preventing our families from
actually
building wealth if they are racking up
student loan debt prime example
uh the average student would graduate
about 38 000 student loan debt but then
dave when we go deeper
a fifth of these young people will
graduate with a hundred thousand two
hundred thousand dollars or
more in student loan debt so a recent
survey came out and found out that
when these young people graduate they're
going back home and 31
of them uh delay moving out of their
parents house because they have student
loan debt
that's one-third that's one-third of our
young people
are not living adult lives are not
living adult lives and your mama's
basement
is not an adult life but you went to
college to become an adult to have it
well it's part of becoming an adult you
are becoming one whether you want to do
or not
yeah that's how this what you signed up
for called staying alive but
and here's when it bothered me dave is
less than one-third
of these young people delay getting
married because of student loans
about twenty percent understand that
right yes sir yes sir one out of five
one out of five
and this is why we have baby set five
this is why
i wrote the book debt free degree uh
because
you have these young people going to
college to go after the american dream
you have these young people going to
college so they can go out there and
pursue everything that they want
but it's the debt that's delaying them
from getting there
and what we got to do up front is start
educating our young people
and really dave i'm gonna say this i'm
going to say this we're not really just
educating we got to ask the question
is college the right path for your child
and it may or may not be bottom line but
if it is
here's how you get into it 100 debt free
well we're not against education not at
all education is a good thing
absolutely uh sometimes becoming an
educated uh welder
makes you eighty five thousand dollars a
year and you're one year out of high
school and you have four years to earn
while someone else is going to school
earning nothing
so you are you know you're 250 000 ahead
before we start the equation um but and
that so and getting an education
in left-handed puppetry as rachel says
is a dumb idea and people go get these
useless degrees and act like that
somehow society owes them something so
we're not talking about that
but we are talking about getting a good
solid academic underpinning
to be able to advance your cause the
cause of your life
yes and that's a fine thing and you can
do that at a state university
with a basic good solid degree
that gets you a job
you know uh supply chain people coming
out
logistics right now making 80 grand with
an
undergrad i mean so you know you do not
you know you obviously can go through
and get an accounting degree obviously
you can go through and get a
communications degree
obviously you can get a marketing degree
there's a lot of business stuff you can
do on one side on the other side there's
other
specialty things engineering
architecture there's all kinds of
degrees that are worth the money
if you don't pay some crazy but
ivy league price for it you can get your
money back it is a good
investment yes but all education is not
an investment some of it's stupid
yeah absolutely and my my question is
what's the roi
if you go to this school if you get this
degree can you get a job will it be a
good return on your four years and the
money that you spent
so when i started teaching this stuff 30
years ago we would
interview people and a survey would tell
us
98 of parents are planning
for their kids to go to school okay
seven percent were saving for their kids
to go to school
so in other words i'll talk no do big
hat no cattle
right big discussion no actual getting
ready to send them
i mean i guess you didn't have a plan
how you consume school maybe government
welfare was the problem or
or dave did they did they not save or
were they planning on just taking this
they just talked in their head it was a
good idea
until they went to the pizza place and
spent this week's paycheck
you know or until they needed to go to
the dadgum all-inclusive whatever
at cancun yeah and uh all of a sudden
kids college takes a back seat because
they weren't budgeting for it they
weren't actually freaking doing it
they were discussing it nowadays it's
shifted
and there's actually of the people that
say that they think they should be
saving a high percentage are actually
doing something yes
so saving at baby step five you know
four five and six we teach you to do
together you're out of debt you have
your emergency fund you're putting money
into retirement it's for
kids college is five meaning saving
investing for kids college
yes that's important yeah but dad and i
want to say this because you said four
five six and seven is all
done at the same time we are not saying
sacrifice your retirement no i said 15
of your income exactly i just want to
make sure people then you move on to
baby step five
four is fir before five yes that's yeah
you'll learn that in college
four is first you put fifteen percent of
your income into retirement
and then five you do kids college yeah
and then the six you with any other
money you can find you pay off the house
early right right and this is what
millionaires are doing
baby step millionaires the everyday
millionaires that we're talking to all
the time
this is how they're living it's what
they're doing and then if they're if
they got the 529 full and that
particular kid doesn't go to school or
they get a bunch of scholarships
you can move that money around you can
do different stuff with it you're not
stuck
but you are stuck if you're broke and
here's what millionaires are not doing
they're not taking out parent plus loans
they're not allowing their kids to go
out there and sign for student loans
they're saying no this is what you're
going to do and if you want me to pay
for if you want me to help you with it
then you're going to a local community
college you're going to a local end
state
but we're not signing for any loans why
because i love you
don't allow your your child to make a
child decision a kid decision to
an adult choice no no don't do it yeah
you don't get to decide
because that's where uh my girlfriend
goes oh lord this is not how you pick a
college
it's uh but people do yeah they do
people do and a lot of them one girl
called you and i are here on the air a
few months ago and she's like
i want to go to so-and-so because the
town is pretty
shoot me i was laughing at that one dave
one of them said i want to go to this
college because my boyfriend is going
there
yeah i just wanted to scream yeah it's
the same thing
and so yeah moms and dads you have to be
good parents
and teach them how to go to school where
they can afford it where you can pay
cash for
it you need to save money so that you
can cause all of this to happen
in your college 529s get in touch with
one of our smartbuster pros and you can
get that done
guys this is very doable yeah but you
just have to start actually
thinking about it and doing something
about it it's very doable
debt-free degree is the book yes by
anthony o'neil
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to puretalk
they use the same network as the larger
providers for much less
for just 30 a month get unlimited talk
text and
six gigs of data with no contract
the average family saves over seventy
dollars a month by switching
to pure top just go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey
to save 50 off your first month pure
talk
simply smarter wireless
[Applause]
[Music]
anthony o'neil ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five brayden's in memphis hi
braden how are you
hey dave hey anthony how y'all doing
great man how can we help
so i've got a quick question for you um
i'm 21 years old
i have 60 000 cash saved up um i have a
8
000 emergency fund and me and my wife
have we've been married for almost three
years now we've been renting the house
for my dad
for about two years now and
he's offered to sell it to us for a
pretty generous
um amount that he was willing to give it
to us for so it just
appraised for about 215 to 220
and he's won't sell it to us for 140.
excellent and um
i was just wondering am i in the
position to go on and do that
um my only concern is that it is an
older house it's it's been in our family
for 70 years now
and um so it is older but it's in really
good shape um
is that something smart that i should do
or should i hold off and keep renting
braden how much what's your household
income right now
so our household income is about 55 to
60 000.
okay 55 to 60 000. and um
you have no other debt no debt good for
you
well done you guys got started early and
you did well yeah
good good work thank you okay everything
here sounds fine on the numbers
uh the only red flag i heard was it's a
family heirloom
what happens when you want to move well
we've already
discussed that and um he's perfectly
okay with that i mean there's no
big connection to it it's just it was
his dad's dad's and then got handed down
and he ended up buying it from someone
else that moved into it
um and so he bought it from him so
you're not gonna have something
you're not gonna have your mother mad or
some uncle matt or something like that
if you're somebody not
no no sir okay they're not gonna win a
piece of the uh
profit when you sell it and make that
extra hundred thousand dollars that he
missed out on
no sir so when i um i'll take out a 80
000
loan to um you know put after i put my
60 down
and and then it will be deeded over to
me and that's it
for them i like it then go get it yes i
would do that
i definitely would do that there's
nothing wrong with it at all and here's
the thing if you don't have to live
there forever
sure don't if the thing starts giving
you fits because of its age
make a move later so 10 years from today
your life is going to be way different
than it is right now
yes sir we were actually gifted um a
hundred acre farm last year
from my grandpa and so our ideal
situation is to build over there
really what i was wanting to do and
instead of paying rent in this house
would be putting my money into the
equity back into the house that way when
we're ready financially to pay cash for
the house that we want to build on the
farm then we can sell that house and
just dump it all into the next house
a wonderful plan all right beautiful now
the other the only other thing is i want
your dad to check with his tax advisor
because he is giving you equity in
excess of
gift tax limits and so he may need to
file
a uh a gift tax filing with his income
tax
and if you can remember this phrase
teach him this phrase a
unified estate tax credit
he may want to use some of his estate
exemption to be able to give you this
gift without paying
taxes otherwise he could get dinged with
some gift tax in the event of an audit
because he gave you a very very large
gift
in excess of uh what is allowed right
now without taxes
and so um you know that that's
you know the whole process so having
having check with his
uh tax advisor on that and figure out
exactly
what the best plan is to do that the
best way to do it but probably a unified
estate tax credit
is going to be the best direction hey
man thanks for the call
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five you jump in we'll talk
about your life and your
money anthony o'neil is my co-host today
john is in grand rapids michigan hey
john how are you
i'm great it's a pleasure to speak to
both of you um
thank you so i have a recorded
land contract that i uh lived in
um i owe 40 and it's worth 90.
and i ended up travel nursing so
i turned it into a rental property i do
go back to the area often
and i would like to move back there one
day and limit it
so my question is i know you hate land
contracts i hate land contracts
i have an opportunity to get the 40 000
from a credit union
do it just take a personal loan pay it
off do it
okay do it and get the property in your
name
the property's not currently in your
name
correct it's dangerous yeah yeah
really dangerous i know but so yeah i
just i just i just wanted to make sure
taking the person along was the right
way to do it that's a yeah it's
definitely it's a forty thousand dollar
loan and you know
just uh uh credit union will do it if
they've wanna if they wanna put a
mortgage against the property they could
uh make sure it's a fixed rate no
closing costs with a credit union
it's a tiny little loan a mortgage
company doesn't want to screw with a 40
000 loan
okay and so uh
yeah credit union is the way to go fixed
rate no closing costs
no uh you don't need an appraisal uh
i mean this is a this is a a brainless
loan it's an it's a no-brainer
easy easy to make and but you don't you
don't want a land contract anthony for
folks that don't know the land contract
is where you have a
it's also called a contract for deed
which means the property is not
deeded to him yet he has a contract
under which he's paying payments and
when he pays
all the payments meaning pays off the
debt then he gets the deed
the problem with that is if something
happens to the seller
like they get sued for a traffic
accident for 500 million dollars
that becomes a lien on their deed and
the deed is not in his name
these things are dangerous wow so get it
in your name you have way too much
equity laying there fifty thousand
dollars at risk of the seller
accidentally doing something stupid they
get an irs lien on them it clouds your
title
they get all kind all kinds of things
can happen because not titled to you
the title is in someone else's name even
though you have recorded it
you can have an option to purchase a
piece of property and record the option
it just lets people know you have an
option but it doesn't keep that seller
from messing up the title
before you get it in your name and
that's what this is in a sense it's an
option
and when he says recorded that's nice
that lets other people know that the
property is tied up
yeah but it does not keep you from uh
getting in a screwed up mess
if the seller does so yeah you go get a
loan it doesn't get the property in your
name asap
okay okay that's what we're talking
about there
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five our question of
the day comes from blinds.com find out
for yourself why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings
free samples free shipping and with the
new promos they run all the time you'll
save even more
use the promo code ramsey to get the
best possible
deal so dave today's question comes from
jacob out of indiana he says my mortgage
payment is nine hundred and ten dollars
and my only
other debt is a thirty six thousand a
loan from my grandfather
which i used to pay for college my
monthly income is four thousand dollars
and i'm currently paying two thousand
dollars a month to
him my fiancee wants to help pay my
grandfather back to get us
out of debt quicker should i let her
help with this
even though we aren't married yet or
should we wait until we get married to
clean
up this debt uh dave if i was talking
directly to the fiance
i would tell her to park that money in
the savings account and then the moment
you all get married cut that check
to you uh but if um um
you know if you all don't get married i
would hate for her to be out of that
money
um so that that's my two cents what i
would tell her yeah
there is no we you're not married right
there's a we
after you're married and so uh
help us get out of debt she ain't in
that honey you are
uh until she marries you and then she's
a we okay
so yeah that's exactly right that's
exactly how you do it
it feels so it feels so different and
say no to getting help
it's easier to say no to helping
yeah well that's true that's true it was
tough it was a tough note for me i was
like oh
man but here's the thing i mean i the
most bizarre one i've ever had of these
was i was coaching
um a young woman and her uh
she had paid off a bunch of her fiance's
debt and he got killed in a car wreck
before they got married
and so what does she do does she ask his
parents to give her the money back
no no i mean you're just it's messed up
yeah
yeah it's messed up and so that was the
most bizarre and sad one but
uh more times than that it's not not
it's not that it's a breakup
yes and sometimes this back and forth
stuff before you're married
causes relationship problems facilitates
the breakup yeah
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's special savings
[Music]
[Music]
anthony o'neil ramsey personality is
my co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five
five two two five chris and steph are
with us
they are in minneapolis minnesota with a
debt-free scream
what's up guys
well we're feeling pretty debt-free how
are you dave well you sound like you are
that's awesome how much did you pay off
we paid off 66 000 in 41 months
good for you and uh what was your range
of income during that time
our range was 71 000 to 80 000. good
what do you guys do for a living
well we're both teachers and we do a lot
of side stuff
um steph runs the children's theater
company throughout the year
uh through the summer she does uh gig
working with the
grocery delivery and i managed to
donate plasma along the side
through my gap in the year i've found
work through scuba diving
valet country club grounds crew at the
park
and delivered packages scuba diving in
minnesota sounds cold
it's cold minus the summer
man even in the summer i mean i've done
some fresh water diving in tennessee
in the summer and it's still cold oh man
that's a lot of wetsuits good for you
guys what kind of debt was the 66 000
well uh 55 000 was student loans
before we were married it was my loans
but it was ours now
the rest was the car loan tires
because i didn't know how to save money
and engagement rings
uh pretty much everything but credit
cards oh okay
so how long you guys been married
they're still normal right yeah
absolutely
three and a half years so that sounds
suspiciously like 41 months so
you get married and it was game on tell
me your story what happened
we started financial peace university
this was before
ramsay plus four summers ago we were
engaged
i read the complete guide to money we
listened to your show we learned a lot
it strengthened our marriage and then we
were gazelle intense from there
we had a baby along the way so we had
the cash flow and
slow it down a bit but once we caught up
we became
another level of gazelle intense yeah
there was another
setback called 2020 and that happened
and we didn't know what happened so we
paused and
saved up but then we resumed almost like
nothing happened
wow i'm proud of you guys well done how
old are you two
29. all right good now i have a question
you said you paused during covet
would you say covet was the hardest
thing throughout this journey or would
something else be the hardest thing
throughout this journey
um we just paused just for the safety of
if we ever had to go back a baby step
but we definitely took priority in
paying off the debt
despite whatever situation that you were
in it's definitely going to save us more
in the future
you know there's always the pressure of
you know we have to borrow more save
less
but i don't know we just we followed
your advice
we stuck to the budget we tithed along
the way
tithing did not set as big a setback as
we first thought
and that's just we want to let your your
listeners know
that so that's awesome i'm curious as
millennials
were some of your millennial friends
looking at you a little weird like
you're like you're crazy
yeah we're the anti-credit card couple
uh
public with that um but you know after
financial peace
i mean the key to getting out of debt is
making that plan and communicating and
saying no to credit and we still have to
say no to credit we get those giant
zeros in the mail with
zero apr or zero money down and
um but you know just build those small
habits of
not getting separate bank accounts or
yours
and my desk and so we just want life to
be simplified
and you know the flyer points aren't
looking too great for us the free stuff
we can't say no to
but we just choose no payments either
way yeah amen
so the uh you know the interesting thing
i'm hearing we're reading studies and
and things about millennials
and and our experience with your age
group uh
but we're getting a a huge rush
of 20-somethings onto the show here and
so we're
we're really really hearing from a bunch
of you guys
but the stuff i'm reading is saying that
this the 20-somethings
are real anti-credit card to start with
they didn't need me to get there they
got there on their own
are you seeing a lot of your buddies
that way or a bunch of them just loving
credit cards
what do you what do you think stuff do
we have friends who are really into
credit cards
uh we definitely do just for like perks
like gas
and uh like chris said earlier um
airplane
flyer miles
they think they're getting yeah it's
it's designed to really
i guess work against you when it looks
like it's a benefit
yeah absolutely yeah i mean it's that
whole thing
you know if we can just get you in here
and play with snakes and one of them
will bite you so
um that that's oh wow okay cool very
cool
so proud of you guys who were your
biggest cheerleaders thank you
oh we had a lot of cheerleaders you know
um
our parents i mean we just uh started
this journey ourselves but
you know your name is a household name
um
we're just getting closer to that
seventh baby step living like no one
else but
it's kind of nice to taste some beans
and rice once in a while
get a little nostalgic you know early
newlywed years
thrift shopping highly recommend i can't
pass up a good deal i don't care
how much money you got i mean we can't
pass up a good deal i love it
that's so fun well well done you guys
we've got a copy of the legacy journey
to take you on to the next step with
that new baby and that's what you're
doing you've changed your family tree
leaving a legacy heading on to baby step
seven and
debt free all the way way to go and
another copy of the total money makeover
i'm sorry it feels great we're proud of
you way to go
also a copy of the total money makeover
for you to give away to someone and
pay it forward and get somebody else
moving along here so
very very well done chris and steph from
minneapolis
66 000 paid off in the first 41 months
of their new marriage had a baby along
the way making 71 to 80.
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
three two
[Music]
[Applause]
i love it that is funny i mean that is
awesome 29 euros man i'm i'm just
i'm loving it dave i i'm loving it well
21 year old calling and paying
putting sixty thousand dollars down in
the house i mean
this millennial generation is they're
hearing the message
well you know i've always said there's
two types awesome and sucks
there's no middle ground with
millennials they're either dumber than a
rock
or they're the best kid on the planet
and they're doing everything smart
either
there's no there's they don't do
mediocre they do stupid with steroids or
they do
wise with steroids hold on dave they do
i mean
that millennial well you're one of the
smart ones okay
you are you're not in the millennial
generation i am you're older than that
i'm 36 is that that's not millennial yes
it is
james millennials are getting old hey
hold up we're barely on the bubble yeah
yeah thank you thank you james
hold on dave just call me old if i'm
getting old where does he
i i'm i'm ancient and wise and
need and due respect
hold up man hold up i'm still entitled
i'm young at the heart
i'm young i'm young you know all right
open phones
eight two five five two two five here's
the funny thing about it
as long as we've been doing this i mean
for 30 years i've always heard every you
know gen xers yeah
they were the ones they were the
millennials back when i started gen xers
oh those channels skateboarders yeah you
know oh my gosh you know
and the baby boomers oh they're just
dumber than a rock
they spin and they're all about greedy
and what was the skateboarders dude that
was the gen xers oh
blake thompson oh but yeah i could see
blake thompson riding the skateboard oh
he's definitely a big time skateboard
guy big surfer too
still he's an old guy doing it now but
that's what that's what gen xers are
they're old now so what is pete then
because pete drives i mean he does
escape pete's
big surfer i i would imagine pete is a
gen xer
is he yeah you beat gen x or we love it
then there's gen y yep and then there's
the millennials yeah
so i don't know what gen y got accused
of but every generation has been accused
of
of having their slackers every
generation
yeah and now boomer is like a that's
like a name you call old people
you're just a boomer that's so funny i'm
glad you know you're a boomerang
definitely i'm a total card-carrying
boomer and dad jokes that's me
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
auto insurance companies love to play
the game
where they see just how high they can
jack up your rates for no apparent
reason right this is fun
good news it's not hard to beat them at
their own game it's called shopping them
all you gotta do is check on your policy
every year or two and make sure you're
getting the best price on your coverage
and if you haven't done that you're
really probably not
at the break we were out here we just
met one of our endorsed local provider
insurance agents from muskegon michigan
just a minute ago
these elps are independent insurance
agents which means they shop among
several different companies
and get you the best price they actually
work for you they're paid by the
insurance company
a commission but their work for you
because they help you
find the best deal and so you're gonna
save six seven hundred bucks on average
when you
have them shop it for you of course it
doesn't cost anything for them to go
shopping for you so
call them get in touch with them don't
sit back while your insurance company
jacks you around for no reason man
don't we all kind of hate this whole
thing text auto to 33
789 and uh put a trusted elp
insurance agent on your team an endorsed
local provider
that's auto23789
anthony o'neil ramsey personality is my
co-host today
jake is in dallas texas hi jake how are
you
doing great how you guys doing better
than i deserve what's up
happy to hear it so i am currently i'm
22 years old i'm self-employed
and i'm getting to a point where i
really want to start paying off on my
debt
building up a retirement plan and just
you know overall being more wise and
more strict with my budgeting
however i'm self-employed so my income
varies although it is steady
um but i just wanted to see what you
would recommend as
a method to build a budget when you are
self-employed and the money doesn't come
in as consistently
but you just want to stick to that
budget and be as efficient with your
money as possible
so what's your taxable income in 2021
uh 2021 i would estimate my personal
taxable income
around 80 000. good for you well done
what are you doing
what kind of business uh i do a lot of
post-production work
uh remotely for different film
production companies
around the world okay any employees
no it's just me good for you well done
well done
well i i think the the biggest thing is
not uh how to attack the debt you're
going to attack the debt
just like anyone else would with your
income working the debt snowball right
smallest to largest and get after it in
that order
okay the question is how to manage the
irregular income
the first thing i would do is go get
ramsey plus and get a free membership
a free trial membership going and get
the every dollar premium version going
because the every dollar app will help
you do this what you can do is just you
can just go in and adjust it as your
income moves around
uh and so that's fairly easy way to do
it old school
the principle that you want to use even
when you're using the everydollar app
is a prioritized spending plan
okay now what that sounds like is this
uh in your case
uh you have a a fairly predictable
stream of income
but if we wanted to go all the way to
zero we could start with and say okay if
i can only afford to do
one thing this month what's that one
thing and you put a number one beside
that on your budget that's food by the
way
okay if i can only afford to do one
other thing what would i do and you put
a two beside that i'll tell you what
that is it's utilities
because if you eat and keep the lights
on you can deal with the landlord later
okay okay in worst case scenario but
you're not even that far down you said
you have steady it's just
unpredictable correct and sometimes it's
irregular
in terms of when the money comes and but
just wanting to so anyway you go all the
way down that list
and when you get towards the bottom of
that list is where the action takes
place in your world
and that is that you know when you get
to number 16
you do 16 before you do 17 and you put
the debt snowball stuff
in those bottom the extra money on debt
moves down after you've taken care of
the necessities of life
and they're ahead of going on vacation
because you're in baby step two you're
not going on vacation
right right and they're ahead of going
out to eat because you're in baby step
two and you're not going out to eat
how much debt are you in right now jake
um if you don't count i just bought a
house um
including the house including the house
not including the house excluding
i would guess business about 7 000 uh
business debt and then
about 20 000 personal debts including my
vehicle
including as far as their vehicle is
inside the 20 000
correct okay what kind of vehicle is it
uh it's a forerunner full runner it's
just it's big enough and
efficient enough for what i need because
yeah you can afford to do
every bit of thing what you're doing you
just need to get paid off and so 27 000
makes you debt free except your house
yeah correct you make 80 and you're
single and 22.
i'm married okay what's she make
uh so she is also kind of in between
jobs right now we're looking
to move kind of closer to back home with
family uh so her income fluctuates a
little bit but
roughly two thousand a month later right
now okay so you got a hundred thousand
dollar income you have twenty seven
thousand dollars in debt
you pay off your twenty seven thousand
inside of one year
absolutely that sounds good
2 500 to 3 000 a month at least towards
this debt
boom smack it in the head now that's
assuming a steady flow of this income
and it's not a real volatile income
but that should be the average over the
12 months you should be debt-free in
12 months easy really a little sooner
actually but the key ingredient to this
dave is what you said earlier he has to
get on the budget
he has to literally sit down and write
out his priorities
yeah if you do not do that you will not
get out of debt
because you're not going to know where
your money's going so sit down with your
wife
and y'all figure this thing out and i
heard you say you you may want to be
moving soon
i would focus on this before i move so
that way
you're not even more unstable go ahead
and get out of debt then let's talk
about moving after we get out of debt
that's that's not a bad idea at all open
phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five michael is
with us in waco texas
hey michael what's up doing well how are
you dave
better than i deserve how can we help
well first of all i want to say thank
you because i am a very indecisive
person by nature and just having the
streamlined baby step process has
brought a lot of peace of mind to you
know me and my household and my wife so
thank you cool work that you've done
thank you so
um my question is kind of career related
um when covet hit i made
a pretty drastic career change from uh
teaching piano lessons with a music
degree
to working in the retirement plan
industry um you know i it was the first
time i had ever made a salary because i
was self-employed before that
um so they had me in sales like their
sales department at first and
i earned the first cert like kind of
company required certification a lot
faster than they expected
uh considering i had a music degree plus
i think they
realize that i enjoy numbers more than
people sometimes
uh so they moved me to the actuarial
department
so my question is i'm coming up on my
one-year anniversary working for this
company and i think i'm at a little bit
of a crossroads you know on one hand
i could stick with more of the
administrative work that i've been doing
for them
and on the other hand i think my
employer would be pretty
excited and willing to pay for my
actuarial certification
training and the exams for me to
actually become an actuary
the downside to that is that i need to
put in a lot of extra hours
every day outside of work studying and i
just don't know if my educational
background is sufficient
for that considering like i said i have
a music degree
and it would take several years to earn
that certification i just feel like it
would be
taking a lot more of a risk if i wasn't
married this would be a different
conversation because
i would be willing to take on that risk
but with well the risk is time
right the risk is time away from the
television
whoop-de-doopty so risk
well i mean i'm not sure whether or not
i have the capability to because i don't
know if i would need to take
yes you do come on they would have
already fired you yeah they're not going
to let you sit in an actuarial
chair if you can't do math for a year
well you're and you think that and you
think they're willing to pay for you to
get the certification which also means
they think you can do it
i mean do you feel incompetent or are
just lacking in confidence
probably the latter yeah that's what i'm
hearing i think you're better than you
think you are
that's what i think oh by the way
there's a lot of tie-in if you haven't
noticed between music and math or so i
hear
yes there definitely is i've always had
a tendency for my numbers i mean
my dad was an engineer dude you're more
of a stud than you think you are throw
your shoulders back rip your shirt off
show the s on your chest let's go okay
can i
i kind of have enough you can do it man
you can do it i promise you you can do
it don't you think he can do it yeah he
can take his shirt off
[Laughter]
you are wrong you are wrong do you have
an s on your chest anthony i sure do
i do too buddy i'm just saying it stands
for
super old boomer
this is the ramsay shop
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in under 10 minutes
check out the ramsey call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw as the
status
symbol of choice i'm dave ramsey anthony
o'neil ramsey personality is my co-host
today
a host of the table on youtube
and lots of wonderful interesting folks
join him for conversations at the table
and you guys uh are you taking calls
from people at the table
not yet no sir not doing this so it's
just a discussion every time i should
know that i listened to it but i just
just occurred to me why don't you take
calls
okay so anyways if you want to talk to
anthony now here's your chance then so
the phone number is triple eight eight
two five
five two two five a o is in the house
triple eight eight two five five two two
five tori is in cleveland ohio starting
off this hour hi tori how are you
good how are you better than i deserve
what's up
um so i am kind of in just like a pickle
of what to do
i've been listening to you for a little
bit now and i've worked really hard
the last like two months to just get
that paid down i originally was
living with someone in an apartment and
i ended up moving back home and
fortunately event however it's a really
like
toxic place to live in and so i'm like
basically seeming to get out
and i i just kind of don't know what to
do because of
like going through bills like i have the
every dollar app and like when i look
through it
it's very much so that i either would
live
like pennies in the dollars or i'd be
over so i just don't know how to go
about this
tori why do you say it's toxic i'm
curious
um like i mean
it is meant as like messing up with my
mental health
and so like it makes things almost worse
because i'm like
i'm like i just hate it like it's like
every day like a problem i i'm one of
five kids and the three younger kids
have disabilities
um so and my parents
just you know definitely struggled to
handle it and
it's a mixture of disabilities of mental
and behavioral issues
so uh just even a quick example like
if i'm sleeping and i need to wake up at
like
eight or eight o'clock because that's
what time i want to wake up i'll
probably wake up around seven
to my father screaming at the kids
and that's just like i mean barely even
a tiptoe dive into like
like what it's like so how old how old
are you
23. and i think i heard you say you
don't make enough to live on your own
i feel like i don't make enough no it's
not a feeling it's a math thing
yeah how much do you have
i my base uh pay is 35 000
a year i make a little bit of commission
each month
on a conservative end my monthly income
is
right around two hundred and or two
thousand two hundred dollars
you make enough to live on your own you
sure do
okay i don't know what all you're trying
to put in the every dollar app what all
you're trying to finance here if you got
a bunch of debt
i have 33 000 in debt it's a mixture of
um in auto loans for 13 000 that is
under someone else someone else's name
but i'm a co-signer
and i've been trying to figure that out
for a while and i just pretty much
the gentleman's not letting me do
anything with it then i have a personal
my personal loan like are you driving
the car or is he
i'm driving the car okay so you need to
treat it like it's your car loan and get
it paid off and get your car
right yeah yeah so i've been doing so
i've been doing that very much so yes
good um and then i have fifteen thousand
dollars in student loans
and i just went from six thousand
dollars in credit card debt
to two 2000. yeah what do you do
i work at verizon okay 40 hours
i actually i'm like i'm on i'm like
actually at verizon right now
do you work 40 hours i do work 40 hours
yes and i've been looking at a part-time
job
okay yeah you need one you knew you do
yeah yeah or
two or three stop looking go get
anything else to do
yeah you have any kids tori
no i don't have any kids okay all right
so uh yeah you do need to get out and
you may just need to get a good roommate
and find out you'll find yourself in a
an apartment situation that's very very
affordable no you can't afford something
super expensive you don't make a lot of
money
but if you got a rent if your rent was
five six hundred bucks your part
um which is very doable in cleveland
ohio
if you had a roommate for sure you can
do this or find just a little studio
somewhere
in the you know garage apartment out
back at some old lady's house type of a
thing
uh it doesn't need to be anything fancy
it just needs to be quiet and yours
yeah yeah my um my monthly payment on my
cards 443
a month and it'll be paid off in less
than three years your pa your card's
gonna be paid off a lot faster than that
because you're gonna get six jobs and
you're gonna pay off all of this really
fast
i want you to double your income yeah
okay but all you're gonna be doing is
working for a little while because right
now here's what you've got here's what
you got okay
you may you don't make enough money to
not be miserable
with the debt and the living situation
so the way to fix the debt
and the living situation is more money
to fix both of them does that make sense
yeah
and if you fix both of those if you had
no debt and
you could make a budget that that you
could live in a decent apartment
uh you'd have a really good life right
now at 23 years old and you'll be on
your way
choosing you what career you wanted to
do and all that kind of thing right
yeah yeah yeah so i want you to get like
six jobs i want you to be a nanny
i want you to be dog sitting i want you
to be i don't care
whatever it is you like to do but let's
go make up some money
absolutely i mean you can make two
thousand dollars a month just
you know delivering pizzas on a week you
know five days a week at night
yeah yeah and depending on what your
education is i want you to go to
tutor.com
start tutoring some kids they're paying
right around 75 to 150
an hour depending on what you can bring
to the table
and if you could do that from home a few
nights an hour uh
i mean not a few nights but a few hours
a night i mean you can really make it so
there are some things out there that you
can do
to generate some extra income to go
towards paying off your debt and getting
your income higher
yeah but here here's the first thing the
first thing is you lay out a budget that
takes care of food
utilities shelter and car payment yeah
and minimum payments on the credit cards
and call the student loan is in as a
hardship deferral
if you have to and then you go get six
jobs
and you start plowing through your debt
snowball listing your debts smallest to
largest
i'm telling you if you go make another
thirty thousand dollars next year
on top of what you already make you
could be 100
debt free in one year and that's going
to change your whole position of where
you are
you can actually do this but your
brain's kind of foggy
because you're just kind of stuck in
this uh job that's not like your big
career job that you really wanted you've
got this situation back at the house
that you're trying to get away from
and it's hard to just do simple math
when you're when your brain's working
like this
so we're telling you we're looking at it
and i think you can lay out a simple
budget
that just says food utilities
roommate rent and uh pay the car payment
keep gas in the car and work all the
time
no life you're not gonna get to go out
running around you don't get to go out
to eat you don't get to go to bars on
the weekend you're going to be working
unless you're working at one of them
that's the only place you're going to be
that's one place you're going to see the
inside of a restaurant or a bar
okay so it's time to get game on and go
catgo
take your life by the throat and shake
it
and make it behave absolutely
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children
and we had also just started a real
estate company and needed to find
healthcare coverage that would meet our
needs
we were attracted to chm because of its
low monthly costs and the ability to
negotiate
medical costs down established in 1981
and accredited by the better business
bureau
chm is here to meet the needs of your
growing family or small business
check us out at chministries.org
backslash budget
we absolutely believe in it
[Music]
anthony o'neill ramsey personality is my
co-host today
this is the ramsey show if you're
stressed
or you're hurting because you're worried
about your retirement savings
well i can help you with that maybe you
were super close to retiring and now
you're wondering if you should work a
few more years maybe kovid scared you to
death
maybe you weren't investing in the right
things or you were investing too
aggressively
and you lost more than you could handle
emotionally
maybe you pulled everything out at
exactly the wrong time last year when
the market dove during covid before it
came back
oh no if you're in any of these
situations i want you to know that
you don't have to face this pain alone
now more than ever seek out the advice
of a an investment professional a
conscientious investment pro like one of
our smart vester pros
is not going to tell you to invest in
something dumb
like gold or bitcoin they're gonna say
the
tortoise wins the race
long-term investing strategies steady
conservative don't lose your money
investing strategies
that's what i do and that's what they're
going to tell you to do
you don't have to let 2020 kill your
confidence in your retirement go to
daveramsey.com or go to
ramseysolutions.com
investor that's ramseysolutions.com
slash investor
sandra is in cincinnati hi sandra
welcome to the ramsey show
hi thank you so much for taking my call
i appreciate that sure what's up
all right so i have a question about um
term life insurance my husband and i
we have nine years left on 20-year
policies in 2019 he became disabled and
spent
that entire year with no income in 2020
early 2020 he was approved for
permanent disability so my question is
we have um
with him being on disability and no
longer working
we have a high we pay 85 a month for his
insurance it's not very much for his
terms
it's only 100 not even 140 thousand
dollars in coverage
and i wonder if it's worth should i keep
paying the next nine years on that
with him not working any longer
uh so you he before he became disabled
he already had expensive term
yes yeah he's had her
yes 20-year term we have nine more years
on him okay
yeah so he had other medical issues
before
yes oh yeah absolutely so it's a rated
policy
okay yes okay so it's only 140 000
but if he dies you would lose his
disability right
that's why i'm not 100 sure
you definitely would your children would
receive ssi
if they're not 18 but you don't receive
their they're grown
okay then
disability payments uh die when the
person dies
you lose them so um okay how's he doing
overall um overall i mean he's not
he's not terminal yeah i don't think it
isn't
beyond where we all are but his mobility
is very limited and you know he stays at
home
okay all the time hmm that's tough i'm
so sorry
um
what what do you make um i make 90.
a little over 90 000. okay and so this
is
uh a thousand dollars a year
is that right yes yes yes y'all have any
savings right now sandra
um we have we actually just this month
after
30 years of marriage i mean this month
we're writing off our last debt
payment and we're going to be done so we
have the emergency fund
we're going to start building this three
to six months fund um
but we also have you know ira you know
retirement accounts about 150 each
ballpark nothing crazy and how my son
um i am 53 he's 57.
my son i would keep it about five more
years until you get your nest egg
building
a little bit better yeah i'm not sure
i'm gonna keep it the whole nine years
but i'm gonna keep it three or four five
maybe something like that
while you get this nist egg cranked up
uh it's only a thousand dollars a year
and 140 000 to go a long way right now
in your situation
but uh you know what i love about the
question is you're actually trying to
think it through
and you know can i make it without that
money if something happened to him
which you didn't know for sure would be
the case until you talked to us just now
but
that is the case so you just got to say
all right
um you know do i need this little bit of
cushion
until i get this nest egg going a little
bit further now that i'm finally
out of debt and i make 90 grand a year
so yeah i'm gonna keep it a little while
longer
but you can make that decision again in
a year
in another year and another year you
don't have to do everything exactly the
way i said it but i think the three to
five year mark is going to make a lot of
sense
another three grand to have the
insurance in place
uh three years from today you ought to
have a lot more money in investments
than you have today
uh because now you're debt-free and you
make 90 grand so that's good news
so dave in this situation uh correct me
if i'm wrong
i like what you said should her focus be
and for to anyone else who's listening
get a fully funded emergency fund start
investing and then maybe put a little
bit more in the savings for
possible barrel costs so she can have
some extra cushion if something
was to happen you might have four might
make sure you had the full six months in
the emergency fund
yeah have a full emergency fund but
that's all you would need okay
it's a good question though yeah just
thinking
uh it's but the point sandra is is
you're doing a really good job of
reevaluating now that things changed yes
and guess what you're gonna do that
every year you're going to reevaluate
now that things changed because they're
going to change every year and so
um you know you may get a big raise your
investments might take off and do really
well
could be just the opposite we have
struggle getting money into the
investments
so we want to keep it a little longer
but somewhere in there
is the plan to uh somewhere in between
there is the plan but for today i'm
keeping it
at least one more year and i'm okay with
a three to a five year plan
somewhere in there i i think you're
gonna be okay towards the end of it
though
thanks a bunch open phones at triple
eight eight two five
five two two five you guys jump in we'll
talk about your life
and your money anthony o'neil ramsey
personality is my
co-host today casey is in little rock hi
casey how are you
fantastic how are you better than i
deserve how can i help
uh yes sir i'm trying to get your
insight um
i have about eighty thousand dollars in
debt um
uh my my highest is my student loans for
about sixty thousand and
last year i bought a car uh about
it was about twenty one thousand right
now i have about nineteen thousand three
hundred sixty four dollars left on it
um trying to get your insight do you
think i should keep this car
i make about fifty three thousand and
one hundred dollars
no no no
no you need to get rid of the car you
should have never bought the car what
kind of car is it real quick
uh 2020 hyundai accent hyundai accent
okay
all right yeah we need we need to trade
this car in we need to sell it actually
and then go get you a cash car you have
any cash in the bank right now
uh just uh 1 000 yes sir
all right uh we're about to go to uh a
commercial here but once dave get done
talking to you i'm gonna have kelly stay
on the line
i'm gonna have her send you a copy of my
destroy your student loan debt
that's going to help you walk through
these student loans but right now you
need to get rid of this car
so our rule of thumb casey that he's
using to do that is
if the car is more than half your annual
income or you can't be 100
debt free including the car within two
years
because of the car then it's time to get
rid of the car the second one is what
got you
obviously 19 000 is less than half of 53
000 so that'd be okay it's on the bubble
but it'll be okay to keep it
you shouldn't have bought it but it'd be
okay to keep it and pay your way out of
it the problem is you're not going to be
able to make that free
if you do keep it within two years it's
going to take you three years
and so it is worth stepping down out of
that car and that's what anthony
that's how he made that decision real
quick so quickly yeah
is those are two guidelines we use
because here's the deal
cars come and go but wealth
is built when you get rid of the
payments
the faster you get rid of the payments
the faster you can build wealth
and the faster you can buy a different
car
but right now you need a beater yeah
stay on the line kelly will take care of
you get your copy of that book
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
anthony o'neil ramsey personality is my
co-host today
a couple of cool looking gazelles on the
stage
right here in ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage it says gazelle
intensity
a little unicorn action on there great
t-shirts that
don't know what a gazelle is it's a
unicorn you put on your t-shirt
oh my gosh
that's fun so uh q and katie are with us
hey guys welcome i'm so proud of you
thank you
thank you guys for having us except for
that unicorn part but yeah
it's a story that's the story oh okay
good i'm glad i'm glad you just don't
know what it is
i feel much better about you already how
much debt did you pay off
116 000 what look at that how long did
this take
27 months whoa and your range of income
during that time
started at 90 000 and we're at 160 now
wow oh there you go what do you guys do
for a living
so i work for a wire fraud prevention
tech startup cool yeah and i'm a outside
claims adjuster
okay good good so uh
27 months your life has radically
shifted your income doubled
and you paid off a hundred and sixteen
thousand dollars this has been a
wild two and a half years for you yeah
yeah so tell us the story what in the
world happened
and tell me what happened with the
unicorn
um do you wanna do the unicorn okay so
um
we have a gazelle group and uh we all
have iphones so we're texting emojis and
there's no gazelle emoji
so we just like hey we gotta pick an
emoji and we're like unicorn pick the
unicorn so every time we paid off debt
we would text in a group unicorn
[Music]
oh man yeah what do those people know
you would think there's everything else
everything else in it right we need a
gazelle emoji
yeah yeah yeah yeah i wonder if we can
sell one and add it somehow
i don't know how to do that brilliant so
your your tech startup guys could tell
me
right yeah we'll work on that okay so
this is the uh
best we can do for an emoji because it's
lame exactly exactly
we liked it we liked it yeah well you
are unicorns because you're very unique
yeah well thank you very hard to find
they're rare and paying off 116 and 27
months is very rare what kind of debt
was this
so we had a little bit of everything
student loans personal loans credit card
medical debt cars yeah
everything yeah because in ao we were
normal hey man
you're not normally anymore you're
unicorn you're officially
weird now that's right rare right i like
it
so what got you uh so inspired and on
this for 27 months
yeah so uh we
we were go we were going into the
negative we were overdrafting on our
account
probably for like three months in a row
and i was just like
feeling really stressed out about it um
i was i started to really look for a
plan and i found you and i was like oh
this is a really good idea it's steps
like i love a good action plan that i
can follow like just give me the steps
i'll follow and i like to follow rules
and uh i you know i said i think we
should do this he was like i don't know
i don't know what that's about and i
actually happened to work for churchill
mortgage at the time and
you uh spoke at the 25th anniversary
party and he was there with me and
he was like who is this guy on stage i
was like that's dave that's the guy i've
been telling you about like that's the
thing we gotta do we gotta follow him
he's like
still not impressed uh and then wow
dave i actually i actually took a photo
of you dave and i was like somebody said
this guy's famous or something i don't
know
and he's not that's okay so then he
ended up going on a road trip
uh relatively soon after that and
kind of magically lost service right so
none of the other like apps were working
for music or anything but
hit the the dave downloaded podcast was
available for him
and uh listened to four hours of dave on
a road trip by himself and then came
back and thought
he had this really good idea for how we
were going to get us
[Applause]
came home from a road trip a genius yes
exactly
i'm curious how was that conversation
when you came home though i came home
and i was like
hey babe this is awesome uh dave ramsey
he made total sense
everything he said we got to do this now
yeah she was just like
that's what i've been trying to tell you
what do i look like what i look like i
was telling you the same thing right
that's so fun you guys are fun said it
yeah i could tell you weren't too
stressed out about it you joked around
had a good time i said all right game on
yes how old are you two i gotta ask i'm
29 and this is my
just she's a beautiful young woman okay
then i hear you that's a smart man i'm
not gonna say her age because she did
look up at you like
some kind of anniversary of her 29th
birthday coming up yeah
you know maybe just a little older than
him hey it's all good so i gotta ask
millennial couple yeah uh dave says some
of us suck some of us are good right
um so you all already on the good side
hopefully yeah
you know so i gotta ask throughout these
two and a half years
uh what was the hardest part being a
young couple
you know having to be this this diligent
being unicorns being gazelle intense
what was hard throughout this process
yeah that was uh
and i told her there's two things it's a
communication
learning how to communicate because we
before this plan we realized we didn't
communicate that well
um and then hope uh one thing that dave
ramsey you're playing does is give hope
um i when she first brought the plan i
was like you go through life you have a
car payment you have a house payment you
have
dad you have student loan debt we had no
hope um then we went through financial
peace
and it brought hope back and then it
strengthened our communication
very cool so you went through financial
business university then yes okay wow
once the road trip is over we go okay
we're going to go do the full class
going very good right so how do you
double your income
yeah um i mean it definitely we we
brought in
and started side gigs and side jobs but
we also just like
worked and hustled really hard at our
like primary jobs as well got promotions
um moved and yeah we used to live in
antioch and so i was a
pizza delivery guy and she worked at
o'charlie's and
we grinded then we moved to michigan
started a website
side side hustle follow christmas did
everything
yeah oh wow yeah good promoted too yeah
good for you guys
well i mean that's that's amazing and
really the 116 in 27 months is
very impressive but when we see you know
the way you did that
was a clear plan plan hope communication
yeah and
game on yeah i mean with the income you
doubled your dad gum income
yeah i mean you throw an extra seventy
thousand dollars worth of wood on the
fire
it'll burn that's true it helps and
funny is uh i called you dave when i
didn't really know who you were and you
basically just yelled at me
and so that's what kind of got me fired
now you know who i am exactly
now he loves you yes yes what did i tell
you that's funny
you said uh because i asked though we
had two least scars and you said uh
sell them uh we weren't married yet and
you said why are you shacking up without
being married
and so we turned it on we turned it on
we said game one well listen next time
just call in to the anthony o'neill show
that's right
and uh you'll be all right i listen to
you all the time all the time
it means a lot to me it means a lot yeah
me too
what would you say um what would you say
is the secret for millennials to getting
out of debt
or all people yeah yeah i think it would
apply to everyone
i mean i think um you know saying no
a lot to write two things or we really
in in the moment it felt really hard and
it felt like
you know we had to turn down a lot of
things and say no to a lot of things and
had other jobs
but and dave says it all the time it's a
really short period like now we get to
do whatever we want to do so like if you
can
really really hustle and be just really
disciplined for that short amount of
time
um it feels really good when you're done
yeah you know it creates so much
momentum in your life
that that um because you guys did
basically 10 years worth of work in 27
months
yeah i mean you just you compress those
time frames and then there's an
explosion out of that you create
momentum from yeah you got the big mo on
your side you know exactly
and it's just very cool i was talking i
did a talk for churchill this morning
oddly enough
yeah they told you and um yeah and i was
talking to them about momentum
and about the momentum theorem and uh
that you know the way you create
momentum is compress those time frames
that's just very powerful i heard that
when i was a little kid i was 22 years
old
at a sales conference and i stuck with
me
you know so there's something powerful
about doing a whole bunch of work in a
short period of time it creates an
explosion
versus doing a little bit of work over
an extremely long period of time which
creates no energy at all yeah you know
and so uh you just drag butt stuff out i
work six hours a week you know no
no no no no go crazy and that you guys
got crazy
i'm so proud of y'all we got a copy of
uh the legacy journey for you and total
money
makeover for you to pay it forward and
for your next uh steps 116 000 paid off
in 27
months making 90 to 160. count it down
let's hear a debt free scream
all right three two one
[Applause]
what a cool couple they're fun
and then call your show if they want
somebody nice
[Music]
so
anthony o'neil ramsey personality is my
co-host
today michael is with us in austin texas
hey michael how are you doing
i'm doing good thank you very much uh
david for taking my call
sure how are you doing better than i
deserve how can we help
uh david i i want your advice i'm a 50
year old
healthy man very happy and i feel very
successful i
run into your videos about a year ago
and men i cannot stop following you
and uh now that i want to anyways i have
a salary of roughly
1 1500 what 115 000
a year and i have a 600 600 000
on my 401k and 100 thousand dollar cash
in my savings account
and i i uh refuse until i became a
private pilot and i wanted to buy an
airplane
so i just wanted to ask you if you think
that would be a good idea considering
that the aircraft
price is in the neighborhood of 250 so
300 000 and i'm planning on paying cash
so there you go that's my question yeah
well uh the truth is an airplane falls
in the
uh you know in the bucket
of things with motors and wheels
and you they go down in value
just like a car does or a boat does or
anything else and
so um the the good news is if you
purchase the
purchase well in the 250 000 range
you're not going to lose tons of value
but it is going to go down
in value they're not as they're not as
steep as
say a 250 000 yacht would be it goes
down
faster much faster but uh but it is a
luxury item
it's a fun thing especially when you've
got your pilot's license that's super
fun
uh and uh you know i don't want half of
your net worth
tied up in it what am i missing is there
a bunch of other investments somewhere
no i recently run into your video where
you advise
to to invest in multiple funds so i i
talk fifteen thousand dollars just to
try out of my only thousand dollar cash
that i have
and i'm putting an investment on the
mutual fund and maine you're right
it's growing fast and i thought okay i
think if i
i divided this and and and put a open
different portfolio so in the
neighborhood of fifteen
thousand to twenty thousand and and it
grows fast in two years i have the two
hundred thousand dollars that i need
and then i still have it eight more
years to work and continue saving
my house is paid off did i misunderstand
you did you
didn't you tell me you make and fifteen
thousand dollars per year
he did that's correct sir so you're
putting in fifteen
thousand dollars per year is that what
you're saying
no i i put a fifteen thousand dollars in
the mutual fund
two a couple of weeks ago yeah
[Music]
following one of your videos but i have
a one hundred thousand dollar cash from
my savings
i know you told me that but fifteen
thousand is not going to turn into 250
in three years
no i continue saving and then also i'm
gonna
wait a couple more weeks and then i'm
gonna open another portfolio
with another fifteen thousand and i'm
gonna do two or three of those
yeah i got you well i mean you you have
the money
uh you're obviously a grown guy you can
do whatever you like i would not
recommend
as your financial advisor that you have
half of your net worth
or 40 of your net worth tied up in
things with motors and wheels that go
down in value and that includes
really nice small airplanes so um
uh you know it's a toy it's a toy it's a
very expensive toy
and you you don't want half half of
i mean let's say a guy had fifty
thousand dollars saved to his name
and he wanted to buy a twenty thousand
dollar
uh uh boat no
you wouldn't do that it wouldn't make
sense because you have too much of your
entire net worth tied up in something
that goes down in value
and it's the same ratio i mean you've
got seven hundred thousand dollars to
your name
and you're talking about putting 250 in
so it's you know
it's approaching 40 percent of your net
worth and i just
i don't am i missing something no no
you're not and dave i was going to ask
isn't it the maintenance on the plane i
don't own one
so i'm just thinking like the
maintenance the gas the to keep it
stored
i mean just yeah isn't that isn't that
doesn't that also add on to
well if there is an extra cost and
everything airplanes are like boats
if they they sell you a screw that ace
hardware would cost
50 cents but because it says marine or
aircraft on it it's six dollars
you know everything's marked up like
eight-fold if you buy it for a boat or
buy for a
an airplane they just go bananas on it
and so it's
everything is uber expensive to fix and
to work on
uh on in those situations so
yeah you're right there's the added
ongoing fuel
other things uh and so forth so i think
you enjoy your hobby
uh by renting aircraft is what i would
do and that's what you're doing now to
get your license to get your hours in
and to continue your your process now if
you if you continue to invest in in a
few years you have
a 2 million dollars and you want to put
10 percent of it into toys
at 200 000 then that would make more
sense
that's that's okay but i i can't
recommend you put
40 percent of your net worth into toys
i i just can't not that's not in good
conscience i'm with you i lie i hear
your heart i hear how you really want to
do it and i want you to do it but i
don't want you to do it
and it be a mistake i want to do it with
you
[Laughter]
well i'm not sure i'll do that kind of
careful about who i get an airplane with
but yeah
i think michael's a good guy but i don't
know him that well yeah all right
casey's in little rock hey casey welcome
to the ramsey show
casey how are you great how are you
i'm fantastic how can we help
you okay yeah i just spoke to you a
minute ago
um you just spoke to me a minute ago
okay well we'll we'll work on that all
right uh julia is with us in colorado
springs hey julia what's up
hi can you hear me yes
hi i just wanted to make sure i just
wanted to ask you
for overall financial advice i am
currently just beginning dental hygiene
school that's going to be
about a year i pay about 1100 a month
for that
as well as taking out some unsubsidized
and subsidized
student loans my husband hasn't been
working for about two years
why he's struggling with his mental he's
struggling with his mental health
[Music]
and so he he doesn't even know if he
sees working in his future um
so i am currently working while going to
school i'm not sure if i should keep
working while i go to school
stop working all of that stuff
wow you're carrying a heavy load girl
huge thug
yes so what is the nature of his mental
health issues
um he just struggles with some
depression and anxiety
is he seeing someone for help
he sees somebody like maybe
once every other month not good enough
not really no okay no it's not not that
i
not that i feel correct no listen here's
the situation
okay mental health is like other health
you work on it to get better
your rehab to get better a friend of
mine busted his shoulder i saw him this
morning he's doing the pt and he said it
hurts like crazy
but if you don't do the pt you don't get
better and he's going to lose the he's
going to lose the action in the shoulder
due to the surgery he has so he's got to
do the pt
the the depression is it's not magical
but
you know there it is very seldom fixes
itself
correct he has a um obviously both of us
and um are my in-laws have a huge
um christian faith background and so a
lot of his
reasoning for not wanting to see
somebody is that he
you know he's continually speaking to
god well he needs to find it he needs to
find a counselor
that that is a christian based there's
plenty of them out there
plenty of mental health professionals
that don't think that faith is
incongruent with mental health
so yeah you're going to be working but
i i need to see a future for you all
where he's working again
because he gets better because him
sitting at home on the couch and being
depressed for
25 years is not a plan i don't want that
for him and i don't want that for you
and i don't want these student loans for
you but i don't know what else to tell
you about this second
so lots and lots and lots of hours on
your part because you're carrying the
whole thing by yourself girl
i'm sorry what a mess you got he needs
to get some help
regularly this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show
if you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register
we would love for you to come to
nashville and tell dave your story
[Music]
this
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios
it's the ramsey show where debt is dumb
cash is king
and the paid off home mortgage has taken
the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host you jump in
we'll talk about your life
and your money anthony o'neil ramsey
personality host of
the table and author of the number one
best-selling book debt-free degree
is my co-host today open phones here
triple eight eight two five five two two
five
in little rock arkansas how are you
jessica
i'm good how are you guys better than we
deserve what's up
good well um let me tell you i know how
ignorant i am in all of this so go easy
on me here and i called on the perfect
date with anthony being there um
so i am the person in my family to have
gone to college
went got a full ride for undergrad and
then for vet school i said yeah let's
take out all the student loans
so fast forward seven years later i now
have 394 000
in student loans so um
loan forgiveness the whole 20 years you
know you hear that myth
um decided i'm not gonna do that we're
gonna bust down and try to
get these i think i can get them in
three to four years what do you do
i'm a veterinarian good yes sir
yep just started an emergency so um
bottom line just signed on with them my
base or my guaranteed is going to be 90
000.
based on commission i think i can take
home gross about 163 000 a year
good um yeah i can pick up extra shifts
so i'm really
like i said three years we're really
hoping to go for this so
i've got um two loans one is 142
000. and that is a 7.9
percent interest rate the other one
is 252 000 roughly and it's 6.8
yeah so i have 41 000 in savings
no other debt just my student loans so
my question is
do i hit those interest rates pretty
hard with that savings
or on my minimum do i if i go snowball
do i pay minimum on that 251
how do i tackle these things yeah yeah
now before we go there now
are you married i may have missed this i
am not no sorry okay
so you're single right now i'm making
163 000 okay cool great
um yeah so you're gonna hit that
snowball now
i i do want you to look into refund
because those interest rates are high
and splash financial can i i do know for
a fact that they can beat that rate
okay so now here's the thing your
refined to lower your interest rate
not to lower your payments not the
throat not to
come any lower okay we're trying to save
you money on the loan on the long run
all right but i want you to go ahead and
line up your debt snowball with those
two loans
and then make the minimum payments on
both but then all your extra money
for these next three years you're
putting it on the on the slowest one on
the smallest one
yeah so the throw the 41 at the one uh
at the 140
right and uh look at refinancing both of
them
with splash if you can because if you
can drop it one percent
that saves you four grand a year yeah
okay they're they're at about four and a
half right now dave
okay so well i mean if i don't know if
both these
loans are going to qualify how they're
structured but if
if you can qualify and get those rolled
in
i mean two percent would be eight grand
a year that's very helpful here it
doesn't change the
whole equation but it changes it by two
months or something
so the what changed the whole equation
was your wake-up call
uh where you had that oh crap moment and
you said i'm going to get in attack mode
and you went to warrior mode you pushed
warrior button on it
very good good for you and um
yeah and you know the good news about
veterinarian medicine is is that you can
make that kind of money
yeah and so you can clean this up very
quickly if you will
if you're willing to work as hard as
you're willing to work and as much as
you're willing to work getting all that
ot
and jacking that jacking up there so
yeah you you've got the solution
you know you need 400 000 and you can
make that in
you know your great income in three
years and knock it out yeah
uh plus or minus interest rates plus or
minus what order of attack but
i would get the interest rates down with
splash like anthony suggested and i
would
attack the smallest one first and use
the 40 000 bucks to do that
you know hold a grand back for your baby
step one and then uh
just lean in and all you're gonna see
are animals for the next three years
not people not people except for the
animals the animals people that bring
the animals in but other than that
you're gonna be working
absolutely so um not dating you're
working
[Laughter]
well now you just got to meddling but
yeah but you you can go on a date if you
want to go on a date
i don't care as long as you're working
as long as she's not paying for it
she's not paying for it that's right
she's going to where she's working yeah
so but that's great you're doing really
good
you've got a great attitude about it
you've got a uh
a sense of awareness uh and
uh you faced the reality you looked at
looked the monster in the eyes and said
i'm gonna kill you we got this
yeah yeah i'm proud of you and all jokes
aside dave i hear discipline in her
voice yeah
she's she's like okay tomorrow getting a
dvm
is almost in many cases it's harder than
becoming an md
wow well think about it you have to
study several species yes
and md only has to study one yes so i
mean
it's serious it's real serious degree
yeah and um
dumb people don't get them uh so it's uh
uh
yeah it's powerful i'm proud of you good
job jessica
all right open phones at triple eight
eight two five
five two two five so what i can't figure
out is how
you get the reputation that if you're
here
that there's niceness on the show well i
mean
dave i think i i think what people are
saying anthony's not nice he just got a
little more swag than dave and so the
swag comes off cool
cool's come off nice you know your uncle
dave i'm nephew anthony that's what it
is
that's what it is you're uncle dave i'm
not sure what he just said
i think i just got insulted but i'm not
sure no not at all
not at all not at all you know it's
called the ramsay show now so you know
we have
you're the vet you're the season i'm the
i'm the rookie i'm i'm
i'm coming in just helping people
understand yeah yeah
you know feeling the nice shoes hey
somebody's got to be nice i don't hang
up on people on my show
you don't have people on your show
there's that
yo that was a good clap that's a good
one there's some detail
that we need to cover johnny is in
boston hey johnny
i'm gonna bring you up after the break
johnny we've already blathered down into
the break here
oh my gosh well let's get this done
folks if you've considered how your
spending habits influence your kids uh
we've just dropped prices up to 80
on our best-selling kids products the
adventure pack is
a family favorite that includes the new
story time collection the financial
peace junior and the smart saver bank
all about teaching the littles how to
handle money
uh that way when they grow up they don't
live in your basement
if you got a teen we've got anthony's
teen entrepreneurial
toolbox it's the perfect safe and
flexible way for them to create their
own summer job
they'll turn hobbies into a real
business and learn hard work
leadership responsibility teach them the
right way to handle money while they're
young save up to 80
shop the kids and teens sale
at the online store at
ramseysolutions.com right now off
80 percent so uh teach the littles man
it's a big deal
that's what one ingredient in changing
your family tree you change the math
but if you leave it to people who don't
have any sense then
it goes all down the toilet so you got
to teach them so they got sense
that's how this works this is the ramsey
show
[Music]
[Applause]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that even in adversity
that you have what it takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance career training
and a paycheck to help you avoid debt no
matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
at the o'neill ramsey personality is my
co-host today johnny is in boston hey
johnny welcome to the ramsey show
dave anthony how you guys doing great
man what's up
uh real quick i just want to say anthony
i definitely agree you got more slack
[Music]
hey hey john i like you brother yes sir
yes sir thank you man that feels good
this is the ramsey show but we just
called it the anthony o'neal ramsay show
thank you man how can i help you johnny
yeah cause he's gonna have to
yeah so i'm 24. i graduated college
three years ago
and instead of getting a job i've been
building my own video production company
and i recently just got a new job and i
want to continue
to grow my company on the side and i'm
just wondering how i should best
invest my new income after i
you know allocate my 15 towards
retirement um i also i want to just
basically have money to invest into you
know marketing ads and
new equipment but i also want to save
her a home which is very expensive in
massachusetts
yeah it is it definitely is why i get
your advice
so what's your total income right now
what do you make in a year
um my production company makes about 25
30 and my new job pays 70.
okay so just about 100. okay so your
production company that's just your
income what are you paying yourself are
you taking all 25 of that
uh i usually put 50 away
off my income for my company okay and
yeah i was using that to pay off my
student loans and i'm
a couple months away from doing that
okay how much debt are you in right now
uh about 3 000. okay cool
how much money do you have in your
savings um
i mean i've been putting all of it
towards my student loan so i got about
yeah 1500. okay so here's the thing uh
and i definitely want dave to talk to
you
um so you got to make up with him after
that comment uh because
he he built an empire over here so he
can tell you how to kill him
he's sensitive you know but i'm
definitely i i feel as if for you man
the number one investment you can do is
go ahead and knock out this three
thousand dollars especially at your age
and get that fully funded emergency fund
up uh to
at least three months for yourself but i
i
i can't talk into the business because i
haven't built a business before
but i really would love to see you
focusing on now
trying to invest more and start saving
for a home
but i do want you to build a business
and dave can really talk into that part
what i would do is just take a
percentage of your production
income and say i'm going to allocate
that to
whatever i make i'm going to put x
percent towards
um number one you got to pay taxes on it
yeah
and so and as a christian i tithe and so
with taxes and tithe that's 50 percent's
gone
40 for taxes 10 for tithe so 50 is gone
then what do i do with the other 50 on
your business income
uh you know i would well let me back up
a minute
you don't have taxes and tithe until you
have net profit
and so your top line was 25 000
right you before you paid expenses
uh 30 was the highest okay all right so
30 000 you pay all your expenses
take a percentage of the 30 and say i'm
gonna set that aside
for growth of the business marketing
equipment inventory
whatever and it could be 10 it could be
25
it does not need to be 50 or more
okay okay then the rest of it you bring
home
and you you set taxes aside out of that
uh
and you put that into your budget to uh
say 15
of that's going into retirement along
with 15 of the day job
and um and you
and then above that we're doing our baby
step 3b so then you just say
and all the rest of it goes towards the
house so that's going to give you plenty
of money
to really start saving towards the house
out of your day job and out of the
business as well
but still set aside a percentage if you
just develop yourself a little formula
like that
and then it's automatic and you say okay
it you know
this month i had four thousand dollars
come in you know 20
uh goes back into the business okay then
boom 800 bucks goes over here to set
aside to grow the business
the other 3200 is coming down through
the funnel and gonna drop into the
uh the the at-home formula where we're
doing 15
of the income and the rest towards uh
house savings
uh so that puts you you know in that
position so that's very good
you should be debt-free within the next
two months oh he's deaf free now i may
be deafening 20 seconds here yeah
yeah that's that's behind him but get
like you said get that emergency fund
bill get your baby step four going
baby step three be going all of that
happens at home
after you set aside some percentage of
your top line
for growth and uh restocking and so
forth robert uh
is in st louis hey robert welcome to the
ramsay show
hey guys um my wife
and i have been married about seven
months so we're pretty newlyweds
um and she has about 105 000
student loans um we may combine
about 120 000 a year
um my my question is um the
the mark the housing market right here
is red hot
so i'm thinking if we sold our house i
could conservatively make about
130 grand on it and basically cover
all of her loans wow um
my parents live close by and they've
offered to let us move in
and kind of rent to own um
well they you know they bought a condo
down in florida so they
they'd be back and forth you know um to
the house and whatnot but
they've offered us to you know live in
it
just pay rent them rent and then we
could make whatever updates we wanted to
the house and
you know eventually when they pass away
it'd be ours so
no that part i'm not doing um
no thank you uh that that's too that's
too weird to plan
for for her uh right
uh but i i i would i sell the house
uh what and just go rent something
and be debt free man i'd be really
tempted
yeah i wouldn't do the whole parent
thing though yeah that's scary
okay yeah i wouldn't even i don't think
that's good for your marriage
especially in the first year yeah
you all need freedom and peace that's
papa dave advice that's not financial
advice but um
yeah i just i i wouldn't i no i i
i i think that's got too many weird
strings and twisted up
uh uh spiderwebs tied to the deal and
it's it's strung out
and it's you know sort of your house but
they sort of might come home and live
there some and
it's back and forth so no i just go rent
you a place yeah if you want to sell the
house and be debt-free that's not a bad
idea
something in the world if you don't you
can be debt-free fairly quick making 120
anyway if you just lean
into it but if you guys just say well
the house isn't our favorite we'll go
rent for two years
and we'll be debt-free and we'll save up
and let this housing market calm down
and buy again
um that would be okay but uh
you don't have to but if you just you
know but
i wouldn't do the parent part of it are
you hearing i mean no
dave i was i was like no no i'm not
doing it
i mean because mom and dad can come home
whenever they want
and we're just now newly married we're
still getting to know each other i don't
want to get to know her and her get to
know my parents at the same time
like we need we need freedom we need
peace um
we we need our own privacy you know and
so i would just go
whatever you going to pay them for rent
go rent an apartment yeah and just start
stacking up your bread
and then once you get your money back up
go go get the house that you all want
eventually but i i would not sign an
agreement with
mom dad mother-in-law father-in-law
right now i just wouldn't do it yeah
i i agree that's that's the only part of
it sounds weird but i
i i'm on the fence as to whether i'd
sell or not
i i'm selling a house to get out of debt
is the last thing i do
right i try everything else unless you
just don't like the house
yeah isn't that a question like if if if
you had no debt would you still want to
sell the house
yeah if we were thinking about selling
anyway yeah
well of course you the problem is if you
sell in this high market you got to buy
in this high market so
you've got both sides of this uh i mean
you get you just walk out on the plank
doing that but that that's uh um
yeah i don't know i i i'm 50 50 on it's
not a bad idea
but i think i think the answer to the
question is should you sell the house is
really
do you just don't care about the house
anyway are you only doing this for debt
and i love the house and i hate to part
with it
then i'd probably sit there and fight
through the debt or i hate the house and
this is an excuse to get rid of it and i
get out of debt ding ding we're out of
there there you go
go rent for a little bit that's probably
the way you answer the question
and then just avoid the whole parent
trap thing this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free
stage jason and alexis are with us
hey guys how are you way better than we
deserve
i love it welcome where do you guys live
sioux falls south dakota
awesome welcome to nashville a bit of a
hall to nashville from there
you drive or fly drive that's a long way
how many hours well it's 14 if we didn't
stop
okay but we did stop
okay i hope so wow good for you guys
so how much debt have you paid off
what was it 300 and
45 000. 345k how long did that take
seven years and four months seven years
and four months and your range of income
during that time
50 000 to 145 000 last year
wow that tells me you paid off your
house
we did look at weird people
how old are you two with a paid for
house i'm 27
29 millennials but he was 28
a week before we we paid off the house
so wow
not even 30 years old and you got to pay
for it what's this house worth
that's a beautiful home um current one
probably close to 400 but we're building
the next one and
so forth and got the cash yeah yeah
just like that yeah yeah because that's
what you do that's that's how we roll
that's
yeah exactly no wait wait wait that's
not how we roll they are millennials sir
that's how we roll whoa
whoa i was saying it in their voice
turkey my gosh all right fun guys
way to go this is so cool
so tell me what happened seven years ago
before anthony worked here
well actually uh quite a while ago in
2000
it was 2006. um is that what we had
yeah so in like 2006 my parents took fpu
and i went through it with them when i
was 13 years old so that's
really where it began began man see i
was rooting for y'all
you know that's awesomeness
so yeah but um then you get married and
you go uh
jason there's this thing like we're
gonna pay off everything
yes yeah when we were engaged uh i made
him go through it with me and
it was kind of a requirement to get
married
wow i mean that's that's indoctrination
right there
i like it very cool all right
so um yeah i took it when i was 13 with
my parents
and then uh jason has always been he's
always been a frugal saver so i mean it
wasn't
terribly hard to get him on board or
anything and he had heard of you before
so that was helpful
and then also um yeah we
actually we had lily uh when uh i was in
high school
so despite having a teenage pregnancy we
still are here today
uh where we're at with our money um
and we rented a town home for our first
year of marriage just like you recommend
and um while we were living there um
we had an idea of how we could get to
this day sooner
wow and that's where the fun begins okay
so we bought our first house in 2013
14 14. and it was a foreclosure fixed it
flipped it sold it and then that's when
we started buying land and building our
houses we live
in and build them do it all
sell it keep moving and we're building
house number four right now
but this is the first time you've done
it all cash yeah
basically yeah okay wow they they know
how they build their own houses so we
don't have to pay for labor so we just
have to pay for materials
oh wow so very cool because me and my
brother in business together we own our
own construction i'm electrical
contractor my brother's a general
contractor so
we own our own business together and do
everything and
yeah that's fun wow very cool good for
you guys that's a great idea
and so this is how you end up with a
house this nice that's paid for and
building another one
yep yeah yeah and we paid paid cash for
my college and he paid cash for his
tech school and a few vehicles along the
way and we had another baby along the
way
so we had other things that uh
financially came up as well so
that's so cool so what are you gonna do
with this house you're going to sell
this one they're going to keep it
we'll live in it for two years and sell
it okay yeah get to the next one
get the capital gains get the free
capital gains that way yeah exactly
very cool what would you say was the
hardest thing on this journey of paying
off
because would you say you made what
around 70 on average over the last 70
years or was it
50 and then it just went to 145 last
year well see that
part of that is like what was it five
years ago i bought into my brother's
business once i passed my contractor's
test
so before that you were going to school
full-time i was working full-time as
electricians i was part-time
yep so we're making mostly 50 through
most of that or a little less or where
around there and then
i guess that 140 is like our gross
before
taxes but yeah what we actually take
home is a lot less than that because our
business is growing and we're building a
built a shop we buy trucks and equipment
and trailers and all that fun stuff so
we actually live on i think we basically
62 000 what we actually have to budget
with we don't
have 145 to work with budget a year yeah
wow
way to go guys and you actually know
your numbers and everything oh
that's so impressive very well done very
well done and so you brought baby with
you
yep part of the debt-free scream let's
get him in the shot what's his name come
here lincoln
his name is lincoln and this is lily
lincoln and lily and lincoln is how old
three three all right very cool
well way to go you guys i love looking
at weird people what a great plan
way to execute and we're honored to have
you here got their debt-free t-shirts on
everything all right 345
000 that's house and everything and
they're
not even 30 all
done in seven years making 50 to 145.
jason alexis lillian lincoln count it
down
let's hear a debt free scream
all the glory be to god three two one
where's that friend
[Applause]
that is amazing that's how it's
done yes well done well done well done
that is amazing very cool
i mean that dave that's the third person
uh today
and there i just want to say in their
20s who have paid off debt
yep and uh paid off a bunch of debt yes
all of them debt-free and all
not even 30. wow so uh if you're just
wondering america if there's hope in the
future
there is hope in the future yes uh we've
got
wonderful uh folks in that age group on
our team here
that are absolutely bright hard-working
diligent caring
uh love god love america doing their
thing
and we get them on this debt free stage
every day living the dream
uh they're not entitled brats they're
not jerks they're
doing they're doing it so just just know
that they're out there
there's a lot of good ones out there
yeah yeah how does your generation feel
dave when y'all see that
you know hopeful hopeful of it we're
gonna make it
yeah you know but if it's all
participation trophy whining trolling
from your mother's basement
i mean that that doesn't give you much
hope right because that's basically a
group of parasites you know and so
and but but that's just a that's a
proverbial dad joke in a sense you know
so you you just have to use some sense
every
generation has had some rock stars i do
really think that the millennial
millennial generation
um has uh uh there's something
uniquely good about it uh yeah
there's there's some things that are
uniquely bad yeah absolutely over here
they've got the
you know the knock on them uh is
is born in truth with some of them but
but
the one we get to meet so many like that
that are
they're mature beyond their years i
don't remember a generation that at 22
23 24 years old standing in front of me
acting like they're 35
right right and uh any of them yeah
i mean and so uh you know
the the the ones that are game on are
really
uh wise beyond their years there's a
wisdom that's really i
there's a lot of things you said i was
gonna say mature right but they aren't
but that's not
it is maturity but it's a wisdom and i
think the key thing here too dave is
what i love is
their parents turned them down to you
early 13 years old she went through it
and so her mom and daddy are probably
extras that's
that's a secret yeah that's the secret
america drugs a 13 year old to
financial peace university while they
were going through the class this is how
you change your family tree then your
daughter's standing up here with a paid
for house at 28.
wow financial peace babies
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today psalm 118 24 this is
the day that the lord hath made
let us rejoice and be glad in it
will rogers said don't let yesterday
take up too much of
today that's the truth wow
good stuff anthony o'neil ramsey
personality is my
co-host today kyle is with us in
hattiesburg hey kyle welcome to the
ramsey show
how you doing miss ramsay how are you mr
o'neal better than he deserves
what's up um i said some questions about
my future right now
currently i'm a graduate assistant at
university of sullivan mississippi
i work in communications uh i am very
lucky right now i got a
good position they're actually paying
for my mba yeah i have about a year and
a half left on this
all right trying to figure out
financially what i should be doing
because
uh that way i'm kind of struggling right
now uh the skyping we get is roughly
about 800
a month um with budgeting
i only get about 100 of that and with
rent car insurance
phone bills and other stuff like that um
student loans i have about fifty
thousand dollars and then personal
and credit card combines to be about
fifty three hundred
um i'm just trying to figure out what i
should be doing
since i'm making such a low amount of
money uh each month
working you should work
yep so my the position i have right now
um i'm working about 12 hour days when
you combine class
and the office work with that um so i'm
just trying to figure out if that's
something that
you have a graduate assistant position
that is 12 hour
days and the stipend is eight hundred
dollars
roughly yeah um you know each day
and very go down to anywhere from about
seven hours you know this is with
classes
um but i'm the lead uh person in charge
for a couple of these sport
programs for their communications um
so i'm just trying to did you take some
of this on as a volunteer position or it
was required as part of the graduate
assistance program
uh uh it's required sir
i don't like it dun song i mean
i love a ga position to go and get your
degree for free
and get a stipend but usually it leaves
you room to either
have enough of a stipend to exist or uh
it leaves you room to get some other
side work to be able to be able to
live they're not furnishing housing
right
no we're uh i'm moving with another ga
that i work with
right now um on eight hundred dollars a
month
yeah where are we each is eight hundred
and you can you do anything on the
weekends or are you working on the
weekends too
um so that just depends also over the
summer um i'm a little
i'm free so i'm definitely getting a job
over the summer but then once it gets
back into
the academic and athletic years athletic
seasons
um it it really is up to
whatever the um
the schedules of the sports are um so on
the weekends i'll be working or i'll be
traveling with these sports
so that is just something that i have to
try and figure out
so kyle let me ask you this let me ask
you this question why
because right now you can't live okay so
let's just how are you doing it yeah
like you can't live oh it's a great
question you've been running up credit
cards
trying to figure out what i'm doing so
how are you paying your rent um
you know with a hundred the rents 480
the car is uh car insurance is about
sixty dollars a month
um phone is about forty uh i have to pay
for the hot spot
so kyle let me ask you this where where
do they feed you
no i ain't doing nothing uh when we
travel with the team yes
you don't have enough this there's
something wrong with your numbers
because
you're not making enough to even buy
food with what you just outlined no
yep that's i have about 120
a month so have you been taking out
student loans through this
yes oh that's where you're eating okay
so you're taking out student loans to
exist you're taking out student loans to
exist
yeah with the 5300 with that personal
and credit card
yeah that's what i've taken out so far i
don't like it
okay so here's the deal a mass mba
at i don't know what georgia southern
charges are mississippi southerners
charges but
uh it shouldn't be that much it should
be 15 20 000 bucks
and uh they're getting more out of you
than that yeah
yes so this is not working for you uh
you'd be better off to get a job
and finish your mba and pay for it
that's what i've been trying to figure
out is if that's something i should be
looking into doing
um just because uh the bachelor's degree
that i got
you know if i could go back in time
which obviously can't that's something
that i would probably
change degree wise yeah but dude you can
deliver pizzas and make 30 000
a year yeah and that's a considerable
raise over where you are
mba cost plus 800 bucks is 10
000 so you know the the total cost of an
mba
through the whole program shouldn't be
20 grand and you don't have that much
left how much have you got left
um but time wise about a year and a half
you must be crawling through it it
shouldn't be but a year and a half
program did you just start so
the most of the athletic ga programs are
two-year program
so yes i just did start it's about a
couple months
um so is this an athletic mba
um so so uh i'm working through the
athletic department
in at the university of southern
mississippi and they're paying for the
mba
oh i see okay and the nba is that
southern mississippi
yes sir okay so what does it cost to
just enroll for an nba in southern
mississippi do you know
like you said anywhere from about 15 to
20 000. yeah
and that's over two yes sir
so you're getting ten thousand dollars a
year and ten thousand dollars for your
worth of tuition free and you're working
12 hours a day and you are going into
debt
in order to survive because your total
package is only worth 20 grand a year
10 of stipend and 10 of tuition and
or less uh and so you're better off to
go
deliver pizzas and pay for your own mba
you'd have a better life
and you'd have more money am i
missing the math no sir you you took
everything out of my mouth
i wanted to quit today yeah that's what
i really
you sound tired you hear it in his voice
dave
sound exhausted just thinking about it
well you're working 12 hours a day and
you don't make enough to pay
to eat right so you're having to go into
debt just to just to buy food
and you can hear that he doesn't like
the fact that he's taking out debt well
i don't and
and it defeats the purpose they're
paying for his school but he's still
going to take out money
just to just to eat yeah it's not worth
it i'm quitting
i'm gonna go uh use my degree in some
kind of way maybe do some tutoring
uh drive for uber you got car got a car
insurance you can do that on the weekend
anything
anything you can make you can make more
money than you're making doing anything
absolutely
and and still have the money to finish
the nba uh in there
he can make a thousand dollars a weekend
dave just from driving for uber
yeah yeah we're hearing people do all
kinds of stuff again pizzas uber
whatever dog walking i don't care start
a grass cutting business i don't care
you can make 15 20 000
a year or you make 20 to 30 000 so
you're doing those kinds of things all
the time
and work less and have more of a life
and
live exactly the place you're living pay
exactly what you're paying
and still get everything cleaned up and
still get through your mba that's
what i'm talking about doing uh so you
need to renegotiate with them
and say you're gonna cut my hours in
half so that i can work a side job or
i'm going to have to leave this program
those are those are their two options
they're about to lose their guy
and you know what they might
they might because somebody would be
stupid enough to do that
well they might they might let him go
but um they might let him run away but
they might need him and they might go oh
yeah we are trying to kill this guy 12
hours a day 800 bucks yeah that doesn't
work
so somewhere in there you got to work it
through
hey man thank you for the call and um i
i think you need to set yourself free i
hear a lot of tension in your voice
that puts us out of the ramsey show in
the books we'll be back with you before
you know it in the meantime remember
there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily
with the prince of peace christ jesus
[Music]
this is james childs a producer of the
ramsay show you can listen to all our
shows with the ramsay network
app on your smartphone browse by topic
or even sync clips to your friends
download the ramsay network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
you